hey I'm Mike passion I'm Andy wood and
we wanted to know which of these
different AIS are best able to handle
different ages of children I didn't find
a baby come close single version in your
library where babies come from
so we've got Amazon echo Google home and
running on an iPhone we have both Siri
and Cortana and we're gonna try out all
four of these devices with eight
children whose ages range from two to
just under six so we'll see at what age
these various devices start to be able
to understand children's speech okay go
go
look there's a Jose here's what a horse
sounds like what does the first thing
here's what a horse sounds like here's
what a horse sounds like what does the
horse say like what does a horse say we
wear this round is a tie Google and
Cortana and who knew that a horse says
whinny irony a horse says the word
whinny do you want to say where do
babies come from
yes Alexa Berg do babies come from I
think they are delivered to families by
strong
sorry I'm not sure about that it was
another time this time Google and Siri
so some a eyes went with a sort of
cutesy store cancer which is a little
bit more discreet but medically
inaccurate other devices went very
medically accurate to medically her
excessively medically accurate it's so
difficult I'm like who is Benedict
Cumberbatch I don't know that he'll he's
Benedict Cumberbatch Benedict
Cumberbatch's movers already there's one
kinder Fulani do it
planet you want to try saying benedict
cumberbatch cabbage they didn't get to
Cumberbatch Benedict Cumberbatch's and
he was better than Hubble back public
cover batch canidates
Cumberbatch Benedict Cumberbatch who is
Benedict Cumberbatch sure some
information Google home knocked this one
out of the park it is not easy for
children to say Benedict Cumberbatch but
when they try it isn't in light station
for talk to God to your Pandora or
are and Ditka sorry I don't know that
where's our doctor gets sorry I'm not
sure where is actor dander there's
Antarctica Antarctica is a traditional
continent in the southern France
[Music]
okay Google where is our dad I'm Joe
Montana beautiful Magnus where's the top
dirt uh sorry I don't understand do you
know where Neal is where is aunt Africa
I heard where is ambassador I think she
knows me and I took it
okay Google with Antarctica here are
some information about Antarctica placed
in arctica here are the top search
results arcticus erased clothing pretty
close yeah words at Africa where's aunt
on to Cup sorry I couldn't find sorry to
give your contacts was and it was a tie
once again between Google home and
Cortana so this one was the lowest
scoring round and in this one it was
less a test of the AI and more tests of
just these children's ability to say
difficult sorry I our public it I like
all parties demo clap sorry I don't
understand I am Democrat that's stupid
of Syria are you on a democrat or
republican that's something I don't know
[Music]
are you a Democrat or Democrat are you
double cop or a Republican it registered
as are you double well this one Cortana
scored the best here's one where context
would have really helped and these
devices mostly weren't able to put it
together
alright results time so different
devices did better with different
phrases Siri tends to present webpages
as authors to the questions rather than
just answering the question
heads here's the thing I noticed with
the five-year-old's is they started to
ask their own question is there anything
you want to ask how does the police card
get a bad guy how do I get a job and
pretty much every device all gee I
wanted to do is find out how to get a
boyfriend how do I get a boyfriend ok
Google how do I get a boyfriend so and
the elite aboard tied for third place
overall we had Alexa and sirak second
place Cortana nanny did it right colt
Anna came joint first in a few of the
rounds yeah but it wasn't enough to beat
the champion from our last video winner
again Google home come a bash just tip
you an edge so if you are Pemberton
coming batch and you ever find yourself
in an optic car and you're a double
craps or Republican let us know comment
underneath